sometimes to do the right thing one has
to accept a degree of appropriate
the issue
in this case is whether a member of this
house had a fair opportunity to make
representations
i wouldn't hesitate to do it again
tomorrow absolutely no no question
government from the top down defending
this town's mp owen patterson but they
underestimated the backlash
he broke the rules that that was clear
the the idea that they should then
ignore that
and
sanction his return to the house of
commons i think is outrageous i think
there are spoiled brats
that haven't been punished for their
naughty behavior he's thinking he's
above the law and we can't put any trust
in our
mps or any mps
number 10 persuaded tory mps to junk the
system that polices them clearing owen
patterson in the process leaving voters
incandescent emergency meetings called
and at first ministers doubled down the
business secretary suggesting it was the
standards regulator who should go i
think it's difficult uh to see
uh uh
what the future of the of the
commissioner is given the fact that
we're reviewing the process and we're
overturning
and trying to
reform
this whole process but it's up to the
commissioner to decide her position
that triggered a scolding from the
common speaker
please
staff members this house shouldn't be
named
shouldn't who have not got the right of
reply or the ability to defend
themselves i am appalled that sky news
is more important
and then capitulation with a full fat
u-turn while there is a very strong
feeling on both sides of the house that
there is a need for an appeals process
there is equally a strong feeling that
this should not be based on a single
case or applied retrospectively
i fear last night's debate conflated the
individual case with the general concern
with that the original system restored
and owen patterson once more facing
suspension for lobbying for cash the man
at the center of all of this was out
shopping when he discovered from the
media he was again facing sanction
defiance turned to resignation mr
paterson announced he would leave
parliament in the cruel world of
politics at once
he maintains his innocence but sky news
understands his obstinate interview with
this channel last night angered many of
those who had backed him including the
prime minister i wouldn't hesitate to do
it again tomorrow absolutely no no
i think
i think the comment promo in there
that he wouldn't hesitate to do it again
a lot of people thought hang on a minute
that can't be right i mean i'm sure
from from humble backbenchers right up
to
to the prime minister must have thought
well that's not right and that was part
of the reason
part of the reason why the government
changed its position
peterborough knows the backlash took
many forms his office was vandalized
after he voted with the pm
it is so unusual to watch a situation
like this one slip through boris
johnson's fingers the prime minister
thought he could take on the standard
system and win like he has done with
other bits of the establishment over the
last couple of years
but he didn't anticipate the scale of
the backlash and overnight the party put
its foot down some blame the chief whip
but in truth people are trying to work
out just how severe the consequences
will be
now there will have to be a by-election
number 10 had paid such a heavy price to
avoid and questions about the pm's
judgment he would rather not have had to
face
sam coates sky news